[Musique]
ce matin nicolas quitte la charpente
pour donner un coup de main aux
forgerons il faut dire que la journée
est très spécial hague et dur
aujourd'hui on va fabriquer de l'acier
quelque chose qui sort de notre
une fois francs
c'est un moment enfin c'est qu'on vit à
quoi c'est sympa
c'est de minerais qu on a extrait de la
carrière donc c'est de la pierre et de
l'oxydé de fer le principe se monter ça
dans un four entre 1200 à 1400 degré de
façon à ce que la pierre de vienne
l'équipe pour extraire le faire qu'à
l'intérieur
sidérurgie version xiiie siècle avec un
four au plus près de la réalité de
l'époque pour la partie basse est une
démarche archéologiques le fond des
fours a été retrouvé étant donné qu'il
ya de la pierre qui va couler donc on
retrouve le fond des fois pour la partie
autres on va pas les retrouver parce que
c'est un mélange d'argile et de sable et
de paille qui va se détériorer dans le
temps on a tout simplement regarder des
enluminures qu'on se donner une idée du
foie
l'expertisé scientifique
c'est la partie de florian le maître
d'oeuvre des documents qui vont du
publication déjà ancien mais qui sont
les références sur le sujet dans son
bureau des ouvrages d'historiens et
d'archéologues du bâti indispensable
mais incomplet les ressources
scientifiques
nous donne les formes les mesures mais
ne ne donne rien si les procédés pour
réaliser ou un moulin hydraulique ou une
enceinte où une cheminée la méthode de
travail pour nous elle est tout
l'intérêt de croiser la documentation
avec une activité empirique tiers que
tout commence en mouillant sa chemise
parce que c'est cette voie là qui nous
manque quand on visite notre dame de
paris ou
vézelay hoggar cassone c'est la petite
voix qui sort du mur et qui dit cette
pierre là je les pose et je peux vous
dire quelles difficultés j'ai eu à
guédelon c'est ça qu'on offre
24 que le chantier son pouvoir retrouver
ce savoir faire transmis de naître à
élèves durant des siècles sans aucune
trace écrite
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui clair théophile et
florian vont à la source l'église de
moutier à quelques kilomètres et sa
rarissime peintures murales du xiiie
siècle
un modèle pour la future décoration de
la chapelle du château
je me demande d'ailleurs été un clair ce
qui tranche un petit peu c'est cesser
cette grisaille qui obtenu tu penses que
tu parce qu'ils s'en servent apparemment
tu voies ferrées pour les contes les
contours oui un compte ou alors est-ce
que c'était du poussier ou est-ce que
c'était du charbon les deux sont
possibles ouais ouais fatah sont pour
toi de faire des essais ce que j'adore
observer c'est imaginer les gestes du
peintre donc par exemple ce petit détail
de cette ébauche du pied on peut
vraiment imaginer le travail
préparatoire qui a derrière ses
peintures toutes les étapes en fait
nécessaire pour arriver à ces peintures
très abouti donc ça c'est important
aussi pour pour nous pour reproduire ses
gestes la regarde les reliefs un oui
c'est fou ça prouve qu'il ya vraiment un
suivi du mur qui est fait en fonction
des pierres et sans se poser beaucoup
plus de questions
retour à guédelon dont l'atelier des
forgerons la pression monte
[Musique]
pour faire
après des heures de travail un balourd
d'acier incandescent sort du four une
petite quantité de qualité médiocre une
victoire néanmoins
la plus grande demande qui fait à
l'extraction de minerais les techniques
et à 2200
elle à votre réussite ouais un autre
pour galon ces quelques morceaux d'acier
c'est comme le four à tuiles c'est comme
la cuisson de la chaux c'est comme le
château c'est pouvoir montrer la matière
en transformation maîtriser la matière
et que cette maîtrise que ce
savoir-faire bas fasse partie du
patrimoine et que tout le monde puisse
avoir cette information partagés
tous les jours le chantier vit son rêve
retrouver les gestes et les savoirs
perdu une approche qui pourrait bien
s'avérer très utile aujourd'hui en 2021
on en reparle demain dans le dernier
épisode